eh bien bon jour de quoi on se parle
aujourd'hui on se parle l'ordinateur
mais vous l'avez vu c'est marqué dans le
titre c'est ça alors ça c'est marrant
parce qu'il compte sur l'éthique et je
me dis tiens un petit bond et reichel
poser dessus et ben non que nenni dhl ni
chrono ni personne c'est une livraison
express de rogue rogge express worlwide
qui sont venus m'apporter un petit
produit c'est leur packaging que je
trouve vachement sympa sur cette machine
là on se parle aujourd'hui du asus rog
flow z trésor je vous ai déjà présenté
une machine équivalente à peu près
l'année dernière on est dans l'idée
gaming à vous connaissez la gamme de
asus rog c'est le gaming le flou z 13
alors ce qui est génial avec ce produit
et je pèse mes mots quand je le dis
c'est que vous avez un espèce de petit
combo avec un ordi portable que vous
pouvez emmener partout facilement avec
vous avec un petit clavier qui se
détache que vous n'êtes pas obligé de
prendre c'est un ordi format un peu
tablette alors sa cp quand même pour un
côté un peu tablette avec un petit
rétroéclairage où on voit les composants
malgé tout vous détailler c'est une
machine qui est super jolie pour le
gaming et pour autant des de la
performance on a une super config et si
vous n'avez pas assez de performances
graphiques vous dites waouh ça va
manquer un peu qu'est ce qu'on fait et
bien on vient rajouter une carte
graphique externe et ça ça envoie du
bois
[Musique]
c'est vrai qu'ils ont fait un truc super
sympa déjà vous savez l'expérience
qu'elle commence au niveau du packaging
sur le côté unboxing alors ici je
voulais passer parce que vous là les
dents directement voir découvrir prendre
en main tester avant de pouvoir eh bien
vous en parler bien évidemment mais
c'est vrai que ça c'est hyper hyper
hyper canon regardez ils ont fait un
boulot qui est complètement cool et je
suis je suis un peu geek au sein de
j'aime bien ce genre de chose quand on
arrive avec des produits qui sont super
canon les ingrédients game contrôleur on
a des cols john x games strategy enfin
bref le truc est super sympa donc si
vous voulez acheter cette machine
d'ailleurs je vous mets lyon badens
description si elle vous intéresse eh
bien vous avez une superbe expérience et
packagée on a envie de le garder on n'a
pas envie de le jeter donc ça c'est
plutôt bien alors avant même de vous
parler du produit vous savez quand vous
ouvrez vous avez un petit bandeau que
asus est venu vous posez dessus et qui
annonce vraiment la couleur alors
regardez on peut y aller le roc flows
est très zen device infinity blade tu
m'étonnes windows 11 14 coeur mobiles'
pilloud pci 4.0 support support le rogue
xj maubert le rogue jumeaux belges
avaient déjà présenté l'année dernière
c'est une carte graphique des portes et
vous n'allez pas forcément quand vous
emmener une machine comme ça avoir une
carte graphique de dingue avec vous ça
permet de gagner effectivement mobilité
ça pèse un peu sur toi ce bordel quand
même mais bon ça reste hyper hyper canon
on va pas forcément avoir une carte
graphique de dingue mais quand on est à
la maison on est bien contents de
trouver un axe de performance pour du
gaming parce qu'on est chez rogge on est
dans le gaming évidemment et donc vous
avez votre xj mobaye pouvait venir
branchez vous montrer c'est vachement
cool une chambre à vapeur qui pour
refroidir on a un écran full hd 120
hertz 100% srgb il pèse 1 kg 1 et il est
épais d'un 1,2 mm hockey mx witschi est
pas on a le dolby atmos le dolby vision
un bien évidemment du wifi 6e wifi si
c'est déjà très très bien et puis on les
certifier pantone voyez plutôt pas mal
pour un truc qui juste sur le papier
complètement dingo et on va regarder
s'il transforme l'essai alors regardez
300 blessés c'est comme ça maintenant
mon père en fille de rugby la machine en
elle-même c'est franchement super canon
on a l'impression d'avoir une petite
tablette à petit un peu épaisses
prennent pour une tablette à
l'impression d'avoir une tablette c'est
un format très compact envoyé avec une
ouverture ici vous allez avoir votre
clavier qui est planqué juste là qu'on
peut venir enlever les c'est comme on
veut et tout ça mais pour autant vous
avez ce qu'il faut là on va se faire un
petit tour du propriétaire avant de
devenir l'ouvrir et de regarder comment
ça fonctionne l'histoire là vous avez un
l'écriture republic of gamers le slogan
de asus vous avez cette petite partie là
qui donne un côté un peu l'anglais qui
est super beau il ya un vrai gros
travail de design qui a été fait ici à
développer dans notre sens pour vous
voyez bien on a ici l'appareil republic
of gamers vous avez cette petite partie
là qui ressort force dans ce trou d'air
au place et marquer la force ou d'air le
chiffre le 06 et puis alors là vous avez
un truc mais il faut que je vous la lune
vous allez voir vous voyez les
composants ici et puis surtout c'est
rétro éclairé alors on annonce aussi la
couleur ici envoyez-moi san intel core
i9 une config écoles plutôt pas mal on
est forcément sur une geforce rtx on va
regarder ça vous avez également une
caméra à l'arrière ben ouais comme ça on
peut venir se marrer si on veut voir
plein de choses un petit ventilateur la
fin ça ventile de tous les côtés vous
avez l'extraction d'air qui se fait par
le dessus qu'est ce que je vous ai pas
montré alors je voulais pas montrer les
ports ici regardez ça c'est assez
marrant aussi vous allez avoir une prise
jack 3.5 en à brancher votre casque de
l'usb à boutons de volume bouton pour
l'allumer pour atteindre sa focus de
capteur d'empreintes digitales non
peuvent y enregistrer votre doigt les
biométrique pour venir sécuriser et
déverrouiller très rapidement de l'autre
côté on va se retrouver avec de l'usb c
est juste un port usb c'est ça pourrait
pas être un peu frustrant et vous allez
voir que sur le xj mobileye avait
pléthore de port pour la maison et puis
là vous avez votre port alors c'est là
c'est le port xgp m aplatir groupe est
évidemment du sbc que vous avez juste
ici on puisse penser un port
propriétaire donc ça que vous avez déjà
dit l'année dernière quand j'avais fait
une vidéo dessus mais voyez on a quand
même un truc entre couleurs on pourrait
dire oui il ya passé pour il manque un
peu de sbc mais une fois de plus là
lorsque vous l'avez comme ça sans lui
j'ai pu vous n'êtes pas obligé de
l'acheter avec le gpu soyons clairs mais
l'idée de cette machine lassé de lâcheté
que l'egypte lui d'avoir le gpu à la
maison ici vous avez le gp où vous avez
un paquet de portes ça on va le regarder
vous avez bien évidemment elle va ce
clavier qu'on peut appeler à venir
retirer vous avez un petit apport pour
venir le connecter sur le dessous et
regardez là ça m'a allumé cette partie
là que je vous montre c'est juste hyper
hyper hyper hyper calme regardez façon
c'est vraiment l'idée de vous retrouver
vraiment ce code couleur au niveau du
gaming et notamment chez asus c'est
juste canon canonissime on peut le dire
comme ça donc c'est super beau donc vous
pouvez soit utiliser comme ça en ayant
un pc mode tablette que vous emmenez
avec vous à venir utiliser facilement
vous le déverrouiller ces du windows et
windows on connaît l'histoire ça va je
vous avez vos applis vous avez tous ici
pour venir piloter mais le mieux quand
même c'est de venir le prendre et de le
poser tac comme ça regardez un même la
regarder là au niveau des finitions du
clavier parce que je n'ai pas montré
vous avez sur toute cette partie qui
normalement est caché il voulait tant
coop l'agitée ta planète rock flows n 13
qui borde la connectique qui est la
clavier avec un vrai clavier un retour
de touche bon retour de tous là dessus
donc ça c'est plutôt cool extrêmement
fin pour autant et puis comme je vous le
disais vous prenez hop là vous emmener
sa source est là derrière gagnez vous
prenez votre temps regrette elle sert à
quelque chose dedans et forcément vous
prenez vous tirer dessus ça vous ouvre
cette partie arrière qui fait office de
chevalet et vous les posez votre
ordinateur alors vous pouvez le pose est
quand même très à plat si vous souhaitez
quasiment à plat voyez comme salah est
quasiment à plat vraiment en fait il est
comme ça soit vraiment extrêmement plat
soit vous le redresser pour venir y voir
un petit peu quelque chose ce qui est
mon cas mais pour les besoins de la
vidéo je viens le coucher davantage pour
vous puissiez vous y voir aussi quelque
chose comme je vous le disais très bon
clavier très très bon retour de touche
on a un clavier qui est complètement
rétro éclairé qui va changer de couleur
en fonction à des paramètres que vous
allez lui coller donc une fois de plus
dans l'idée d'éliminer dans l'esprit du
gaming ici à chez asus vous avez
armorique wright si vous connaissez asus
si votre programme qui va venir gérer un
peu tout votre tour votre pc vous avez
votre température
température du proche voyez que là tout
de suite je tourne sur alors tant
d'espacé c'est bien clair que nous
sommes rapprochés moi ma config on est
sur un intel core i9 2/12 génération
c'est un 12900 hc écrit si noir sur
blanc et puis la carte graphique que
j'ai à l'intérieur on est sur une nvidia
geforce gtx 35 ans tu t'es avec 4 gigas
de mémoire en gddr5 et donc ça c'est
bien donc après effectivement armorique
reich pas si vous connaissez bien pour
venir changer le mode vous avez moi je
suis en mode silencieux tout de suite je
me suis mis à la cool mode turbo là je
vous êtes branché sur le secteur le mode
performance vous et différents modes en
fonction de ce que vous allez faire des
usagers compagnie parce que si vous
mettez sur un mode de dengue forcément
on va venir consommer au niveau de la
batterie et c'est pas l'idée c'est parce
qu'on veut ici prévenir tout monitorer
tout paramétrer enfin bref c'est un truc
qui est vachement bien vous mêmes les
zorra wallpapers ça j'aime bien c'est
très très très chouette ça vient taper
un petit peu plus au niveau de votre gpu
vous permet d'avoir un fond d'écran qui
va être juste canonissime regarde et on
va appliquer celui là haut up là haut le
mais on l'appliqué vous allez on a le
truc est juste juste dingue et voila
voila j'ai tout dit j'ai tout montrer
donc là ça permet d'avoir une superbe
confie en mobilité si on veut venir se
balader très facilement et puis lorsque
vous dites maintenant je suis chez moi
je veux dire je vois des jeux qu'est ce
que je fais je sort l'artillerie lourde
c'est à dire je sors ça ça c'est le i ce
gpu long le vigile police a fait pas
marrer vous avez pas le mettre dans
votre sac sauf si vous partez en
vacances longtemps vous avez réellement
besoin parce que là dedans vous avez
plusieurs config la filière tic c'est
une 30 80 alors il existe aussi une
autre version avec une rtx et une 6800
mxt qu'on peut avoir moi aussi j'ai à
30,80 et ça me va déjà bien alors
regardez cette 34 e vin est très cool
parce qu'en plus d'avoir votre carte
intérieur vous avez comme je le dis un
paquet de porc donc lorsque vous avez
besoin de porc et bien vous en avez vous
avez passé que dans ce sens là vous avez
du hdmi usb à vous avez du rj45 bref
plein plein plein et puis vous avez
autre chose qui est planqué dans l'émail
juste là hop là que je vous le montre là
vous avez un lecteur de cartes sd donc
si vous êtes créatif et que voulait
faire du montage eh bien vous prenez
votre pc vous prenez votre gpu et là
pouvaient venir récupérer directement
toutes vos données donc voyez c'est
vachement intéressant pour l'utiliser un
peu en station de bureautique à la
maison alors pour venir avant qu'il est
bien évidemment ce que savent à tartiner
un peu et puis la même manière vous
l'ouvrez en mode cheveux allez vous le
prenez vous le posez même l'intérieur la
wii vous verrez pas forcément bien comme
ça mais ils ont vraiment travaillé le
design et puis après au niveau des
connectiques regarder on a juste ce
qu'il faut ici et là je vais vous
montrer un peu le switch de quelle
manière il se fait déjà pouvait venir le
prendre vous ouvrez ici là cette petite
partie où vous allez venir le plugin
directement alors ça se passe comme ça
et là vous avez un petit bouton en fait
lorsque vous l'aï branché ça permet de
l'accès de l'activer si vous ne poussez
pas s'active pas donc là je le prends
hop je mange donc la gelée juste branché
il a juste vu mais il n'est pas activé
je viens d'en armorique krayt aidé en
armorique wright vous allez voir là tout
de suite c'est bien indiqué ici noir sur
blanc je suis sur ma 35 ans tu t'es et
lorsque je viens push et le bouton tac
je push là il me demande cliquez sur ok
pour basculer sur le rogue xj mobileye
ben ouais mon petit lapin on y va
traitement en cours c'est parti et là
vous allez voir que on ne va pas être ma
30 80 c'est sur une 30-50 km/h
apparaître les yeux rivés sur une 30 81
voix l'attention tac ça arrive rtx 30,80
donc là j'ai switché sur mon île gpu est
alors bien damman on pourrait se dire
ben t'es mignon un raid avec ton truc là
ça te fait un espèce de gros besoins
mais on se parle bien ici d'une config
modulaire nomades là je prends mon roc
flows est de 13 et bien je peux venir me
baladais très facilement une carte
graphique à rien a envié qui verra très
très bien et lorsque je suis à la maison
je suppose et où sa tartine et bien
jumeaux xgp urgent à venir branche est
connecté avec tous les pores que je vais
retrouver ici donc je trouve ça
vachement intéressant en termes de
conflits puis surtout une machine comme
un peu du bois quand même bon ben ali
diallo alors bien évidemment cette
config allait pas fait pour tout le
monde elle va être là pour des personnes
pour des besoins de mobilité qui veulent
bouger qui ont besoin d'avoir un pc pour
venir se balader pour aller travailler
pour la productivité pour la prise de
notes si vous êtes étudiant et vous
voulez une machine extrêmement race et
puis vous avez les moyens parce que vous
allez voir qu'elle est quand même pas
cadeau mais à côté de ça vous avez un
truc qui est vachement bien sauf si on
se dit ok je veux l'utiliser lorsque je
veux faire des montages vidéo et que je
veux une config qui tartinent mais pas
tout le temps par contre en déplacement
mais lorsque je me branche est ici avec
un bruit j'ai pu is à peu sans temps
complètement mais clairement rogge c'est
pour des gamer donc si vous êtes
d'humeur c'est ce qu'il vous faut en
tout cas pas chaussé intéressant et
votre clavier comme je le montrais il
est alimenté directement par les ports
que vous avez ici au niveau de votre pc
il ya un autre truc qui est vachement
bien c'est que vous avez ce qu'ils
appellent ergo liffe c'est-à-dire qu'il
est surélevé alors attendre et je vais
éjecter le et gpu pour vous montrer ça
hop là je clique dessus est ce que je
veux l'éjecter web apps à l'arraché
comme un sauvage quand même on va éviter
tout flinguer ça serait dommage hop là
ensuite je déconnecte et je peux
l'enlever là je suis à plat
ensuite je remets cette petite
protection parce que bon faut quand même
pas déconner ça évite les soucis alors
comme je vous le disais vous avez ce
qu'on appellera un côté agolli c'est à
dire que votre clavier en fait vous le
voyez là il est légèrement surélevé ce
qui vous permet d'apporter du confort ce
que vous allez venir taper travailler
comme ça donc ça c'est vachement bien
donc ça m'a évité effectivement et
tendinites à long terme et en plus de ça
vous avez un trackpad qui est en verre
regardez trackpad en verre pour avoir de
bonnes sensations à ce que vous allez
venir travailler donc savait que ce
clavier il est vachement bien optimisé
pourquoi parce que il vient reprendre
tout l'espace même au niveau du trackpad
et ça c'est extrêmement doux donc hyper
hyper confort autres choses à venir voir
c'est toute la partie multimédia radio
on va se mettre là on va se mettre sur
youtube par exemple
regarder up la garde il a joué mais
elles sont je le pousse un peu à fond
alors c'est pas l'ordinateur avoir le
son le plus rond et le meilleur
expérience et à côté quand même
extrêmement médium la shoah fond je
baisse
la semaine au milieu
donc bon le son est pas complètement
dingue ce que je vous conseille ici
c'est effectivement soit à venir de
connecter en bluetooth avec un petit
casque soit directement et pour éviter
de la latence de venir vous brancher sur
la prise jack pour profiter d'une
meilleure expérience et notamment
lorsque vous allez venir jouer et vous
avez un écran qui est protégé par un
verre corning gorilla glass pour leur
ajouter de la résistance et alors il ya
un autre qu'il faut voir puisse coller
sur un ordinateur gaming c'est que tout
l'extraction de l'air chaude va se faire
ici là juste en haut par là là là et par
là alors le truc qui est intéressant
lorsque vous jouez que vous êtes dans
des grandes soirées d'hiver où il fait
un peu froid c'est qu'à un moment quand
vous avez les mains un petit peu froide
vous les posez là vous vous sentez de
l'air chaud qui sortent donc ça vient
quand même vous réchauffer les mains ça
c'est plutôt pratique vous avez vos
ventilateurs qui vont me retourne et on
est couplé ici à une vapor chamber et
puis du liquidmetal sur votre cepex
internet où ça d'avoir une meilleure
dissipation thermique notamment lors des
parties endiablées gaming alors cette
machine allait bien belle mais à qui
elle est destinée alors elle va être
destinée je dirais à beaucoup de monde
dans la mesure où vous aimez le design
vous vous êtes plutôt dans l'esprit du
gaming avec une machine qui est quand
même type et keira c'est pas une machine
comprendre pour tout un chacun après
peut-être moi je la trouve super rebelle
comme ça j'adore je trouve hyper hyper
hyper qui annonce cette fois cette
petite partie la rétro éclairé derrière
là c'est me paraît trop éclairé c'est
juste qu'on voit les composantes de
l'allumer enfin je trouve ça juste je
sais pas d'ailleurs si ce sont les vrais
composants convoi ou si c'est juste un
côté design pour rendre les choses plus
belle et et aux plages postionne dessus
pour que ce soit soit sympa mais en tout
cas ça fait ça fait son effet et ça
marche donc une machine qui va être
destinée qui vient déjà toutes les
personnes qui ont des besoins de
mobilité on va pouvoir venir penser ici
à des commerciaux qui vont venir vouloir
se balader avec un pc qui est plutôt
léger design que vous prenez que vous
mettez dans une sacoche extrêmement
facilement on va penser aussi je vous
dis à des étudiants mais il faut quand
même avoir les moyens ce que je dois le
tard et dans quelques instants à des
étudiants qui ont des besoins pour avoir
un pc également de la même manière sur
de la prise de notes l'équipe à côté de
ça veut venir jouer toute cette
typologie de personnes et puis bien
évidemment au gamer avant toute chose
c'est l'idée d'avoir ce combo avec le x
games au bail à côté qui va venir
rajouté en performance niveau graphique
alors ça c'est un coup je vous le dis
c'est tac tac tac tac tac tac après on y
va alors sur le pc seul on est dans une
fourchette entre
1499 vous l'avez dit c'est quand même un
certain budget jusqu'à
2399 en fonction de la config que vous
voulez et puis le iie gpu là le 30 80 il
coûte
1599 euros donc on est quand même dans
un certain tarif donc si vous voulez
après fonderie fondé bundle pour avoir
les deux en même temps vous allez
commencer sur un i7 avec un écran 80
fléchissement de 100 verte sont nés à
3499 et puis on peut monter jusqu'à 3000
799 euros pour avoir le bundle alors moi
ma config que j'ai ici moi sur le pc
seul mois c'est donc un oeil neuf avec
16 giga de ram et un terrain de stockage
avec une 30 50 pays je suis à 2199 euros
rien que le pcpc que la vie comme il est
là le sgp vous avez de config celle avec
la 34e 20 à 1399 et puis vous en avez
également la celle dont j'ai parlé tout
à l'heure qui est 1599 et moelleuse gpu
budget comme je voulais dit le 30 80 il
est à
1399 ce qui nous fait quand même un
petit tarif d'ensemble on ait à aller
3598 pour la config que je cherche je
voulais dire c'est pas destiné à tout le
monde quand je parle à des étudiants qui
veulent prendre de la prise de notes en
cours il faut quand même posé 3500 euros
3600 euros sur la table pour avoir cette
machine là bien évidemment c'est
extrêmement cher par contre c'est une
machine qui fait honte gaming pour de la
mobilité on a tout en gros travail qui
est fait ici on a un paquet de
connectique donc ça dépend réellement
vous vos usages que vous voulez en faire
bien évidemment pour venir lâche t il
faut être dans l'idée de vouloir une
vraie machine de gaming avec de la
performance croient pouvoir venir
balader très facilement et soir
facilement oui oui et non parce qu'il
faut quand même laissé le gpu à la
maison sans quoi c'est rapidement un
petit peu la galère mais c'est vachement
bien moi je vous c'est très chouette
alors c'est pas un produit qui est
destiné à tout le monde c'est une
évidence absolue mais si vous êtes dans
l'univers du gaming si vous voulez un
produit de mobilité un produit
détachable un peu 2 en 1 avec une config
beaucoup plus musclée à la maison et
bien je pense que ça peut vraiment être
intéressant s'il vous intéresse verdict
les noirs en bas en commentaire et s'il
vous plaît jouez bien évidemment tous
les liens en bas dans la description 1
puis on se dit quoi nous on ne vit pas
très bientôt pour continuer à parler de
take on va parler de paix c'est pas mal
de pc carrière en ce moment il ya
beaucoup de nouveautés smart voix il ya
beaucoup d'acteurs tous les côtés des
tests et puis il y aura également des
conseils d chaplin truc donc c'est
vachement cool voilà le jeu très content
de vous montrer ça parce que j'adore les
nouveautés je dois voir de nouveaux
produits et puis quand on a un produit
qui est fonctionnel qui est beau qui est
pratique cher certes mais pratique est
beau et bassam alive voilà je vous
embrasse pour les sauver a très vite et
bien
[Musique]